في الولايات المتحده المنافسه داخل الحزب
الجمهوري تشتد لنيل الثقه للترشح في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله فالطريق لنيل
لقب سيد البيت الابيض لن يكون يسيرا هذه
المره مع دخول نائب الرئيس الامريكيه
السابق مايك بينس خط المواجهه وتكثيف
تحركاته القائمه على تصيد اخطاء الرئيس
ترامب وفق تقرير صادر عن صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز سيحاول بينس من خلال تحالف السوبر
باك اعتماد استراتيجيه تظهره كرجل مناسب
وخيار فريد لقياده الولايات المتحده
واعاده الحزب الجمهوري الى ايام ما قبل
ترامب حيث سيعمل بانس في حملته الانتخابيه
التي سيتم الاعلان عنها في الاسابيع
المقبله على الضغط مره اخرى على الحوار
الوطني والتركيز على كسب الناخبين
الانجيليين وصقور الامن القومي في ولايه
ايوا التي ستكون المحطه الاولى للمتنافسين
الجمهوريين على الرئاسه فالحمله
الانتخابيه التي اختار بينسن ان تكون تحت
شعار ملتزمون مع امريكا وهي مجموعه كبيره
من المؤيدين سيقودها
وهو صديق المقرب الذي عمل معه في الكونجرس
ستعيد تقديم مايك بينس الى البلاد ليس
كنائب للرئيس ولكن بصفته محافظا حقيقيا من
الناحيه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والشق
المتعلق بالامن القومي وفق مراقبين خصوصا
وان بينس سيتخذ موقفا دفاعيا على الاراء
التي كانت ذات يوم قضيه معياريه لحزبه
ابرزها تبني موقف متشدد لدعم حظر الاجهاض
الفيدرالي وتعزيز التجاره الحره
لمتابعه المزيد
من البرامج وال
قصص والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا
تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات